hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in ninberg in
1893 it's a game between none other than
uh the great zigbar tarash who's also a
medical doctor and I'm sure you guys
have heard of him as he has been one of
the strongest players
um at the end of the 19th century and
also at the beginning of the 20th
century uh he had extremely good results
against wilhamsteinitz who yes I'm still
making a Saga on and I will uh inform
you guys how that is going but let's
stick with the game now and even after
that even after he uh well he didn't
decline but he didn't pursue his title
match against Stein it says he had too
much work to be done as a medical
protection practitioner he later
challenged Stein is for the title he
lost to that but even after that for
example if you remember in The
capablanca Saga we covered the great uh
Saint Petersburg Tournament of 1914. uh
finished in fourth place behind world
champion manual Alaska at the time in
future world champions Jose rol
capablanca and Alexander
so definitely a strong player and for
those of you who are not new to chess
definitely does not need any
introduction but as many people are new
to chess I thought I'd bring it up and
his opponent for this game is uh Mr or
maybe even Mrs Romberg I do not know as
that's the only thing we know the name
but after yesterday's game I thought
that you guys deserved a real bloodbath
and this game definitely delivers so as
usual I'm wearing a hoodie to honor the
hoodie guy here hope you guys are doing
the same uh and uh one more thing before
we check out the game I don't know if
you heard the news chess.com has
officially acquired the entire play
magnets Group which means that chess.com
now owns all of the things that were
associated with um the play Magnus Group
which means the the meltwater Champions
chest or chessable chest 24 the Magnus
chess Academy play Magnus app uh
absolute aim Chess ijust.net at Ginger
GM and new in chess so yeah something uh
yeah maybe you guys haven't heard the
news but yeah it's a pretty pretty big
merger and the Magnus also signed with
chess.com as their brand ambassador and
he will be playing in pretty much every
event that chess.com has to offer such
as the title Tuesday such as the
speeches Championship even the protest
league and I'm sure there there will be
a lot more and if you guys want you can
even there's a very nice interview with
Danny wrench if you guys are interested
I will put a link to it in the
description below will be the first
thing you will see but now let's check
out the game uh truly a remarkable one
you guys will enjoy it
um I mean this is how you want to start
your day so let's check it out uh tarash
with the white pieces opens with Ponte
E4 as players usually did in those days
sorry about that
uh are a mystery person Romberg or
replies with Ponte E5 we have Knight to
F3 Knight to C6 and now Pawn to D4 so
taraj goes for the scotch opening with e
Captain D4 and now Bishop to C4 this is
the scotch Gambit asking black are you
maybe interested in another Pawn with
something like Bishop to B4 check we're
gonna play C3 and you can capture
another one but uh we have Bishop to C5
here and this is the more sound approach
even by today's standards this is the
the correct way to play this and usually
nowadays we would see C3 here that's
very nice but in those days Knight the
G5 of course stylus goes immediately
after that F7 Pawn uh remember the fans
would Knight to a knight to H6 and now
again if this was a modern game we would
uh immediately see a trade and we've
seen this in many games as the queen H5
will connect with the bishop on C5 so of
course you know you can just trade
everything Bishop characters Knight
captures Knight captures King captures
and queen H5 check will keep will pick
up the bishop E5 and okay nothing
spectacular here black can play this
we've seen many game many games where
morphy plays this we've even had some
Modern games uh with such ideas where
black does very very nice but instead
Bush Queen to H5 putting more pressure
on this F7 square and now we have
Castles by black we have Ponta F4 and it
is not as of move 7 that this position
has never been reached again and for
good reasons because black is just much
better here if this was a modern game
and I assure you it's not it's been
played in 1893. uh D5 will be played
which attacks the bishop threatens to
open up the center releases the dark
Square Bishop I mean this is pretty much
a completely unplayable for white if the
shop captures on D5 you can just bring
the queen into the game and there's no
good way to continue the game with white
white king is just stuck in a in a a
very poor Square also if you Castle then
this diagonal opens up D3 which check is
coming if you advance the pawn on the F5
hope for F6 than even Bishop captures an
F5 is an option if you capture it in
Queen captures on D5 black is completely
crushing it here but those were the uh
the old olden days and the olden ways
and the queen to E8 was played adding
another Defender to the F7 pawn and
putting pressure on that E4 Pawn so here
we have Castles by tarash and now comes
Pawn to D3 with check white is greedy
for more material and goes after the C2
Pawn which seems pretty incredible he
defended he castled his King to safety
and he will have a beautiful pass Pawn
already on C2 so King H1 by tarash and
now D captures and C2 with the D5 black
will still be better but the D captures
on C2 and now tarsh plays Knights the C3
and now there is no more D5 and the
Knight has an excellent outpost on D5 so
how can black play this D6 is played and
now comes Pawn to F5 which is now a
spectacular move we have knighted the E5
at attacking the bishop on C4 and now
look at this Knight the D5 and what is
happening here why is tarasha offering a
full Bishop on C4 well the problem is if
you capture the bishop on C4 then Knight
the F6 with check happens and now uh
that doesn't really matter what you do
if you play if you just move the king of
course you blunder your queen but if you
capture here uh then Queen captures on
H6 and look at this uh if captures on G5
F6 and Checkmate is Unstoppable so
that's why the Knight on C4 is off
limits so after Knight to D5 we have
King the h8 avoiding any any tricky
checks like Knight to F6 but it is also
uh means big trouble for black so Pont
F6 and now what white allowed is black
to play Bishop to G4 so how is that
white Queen to escape this mess Bishop
to G4 was played and now the position is
completely winning for white as it was
many moves ago but you guys have to
figure it out it's not easy it's it's a
spectacular Force to Checkmate so feel
free to pause the video and spot this
Force Checkmate in 11 moves uh while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on sporting uh not
just the queen sacrifice but also the
Rook sacrifice and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is f
captures and G7 with check King to G7
and now look at this queen captures on
H6 with check so you have to capture the
queen if you don't Queen captures on H7
will be Checkmate so King captures an H6
and now Knight the H and Knight the E6
with check this is the only discovery
that wins the game so Tara should really
have to see far for this one night the
E6 check for the moment prevents the
king from going back to G7 and now if
you go to G6 then it's a very clean mate
Rook F6 check King H5 and Rook to H6
will be Checkmate as the bishop Rook
combo uh Works spectacularly so instead
King the H5 was played on versus but
what now what can you play now Knight
Dita F4 with check again forcing black
to go back King to H6 black says all
right you can do another Discovery but
there's nothing you can connect the
discovery with but look at this Knight
the E2 with check King to G6 and now how
to continue the attack uh only one move
wins for black for white it's a force
made in three but again not an easy one
to spot uh Rook to F6 with check and
what this does is forces the king to a
dark square and then Bishop comes into
the attack the bishop will control F6
and H6 and then you can deliver a
spectacular knight checkmate so Rook the
F6 with check another beautiful
sacrifice now if King to H5 will repeat
Rook to H6 Checkmate so this is
impossible King captures on F6 has to be
played and now Bishop to G5 with check
King's the G6 and now the Knight that
delivered so many checks now Returns the
F4 only this time it returns with
Checkmate so absolutely Spectacular Now
the bishop here is guarded by the knight
uh the pawn covers the F5 Square the
Knight covers the H5 Square Bishop
covers H6 and F6 and the Knight covers
the G7 square and that's all there is
for the black king it was a very nice
game a very nice play very nicely played
by both of them but it really shows how
a modern chess evolved and that if if
you tried to play this with white even
though the the opening and the line and
the Gambit everything is perfectly fine
but at some point you would have to say
all right let's
um you know let's not push it let's go
go for Knight cappers on F7 or Bishop
captures on H on F7 go for Queen H5
check pick up the bishop and C5 and okay
nothing spectacular for white we play a
nice game but in in those days in 1893
where uh such things were still unknown
especially by by weaker players maybe on
the absolute top level level you would
see this but as we do not who our good
friend Romberg was uh well he just
didn't defend all that properly but uh
you can never achieve such a spectacular
Checkmate or such a spectacular attack
or a game with you know absolute perfect
defense sometimes a mistake has to be
made or even a slight inaccuracy would
be enough for a masterpiece to occur and
this is what happened here so yeah
brilliant game uh wonderful stuff by uh
by uh one of the greatest players of the
era in the medical doctors
once again thank you Piers job for
suggesting such a nice game really
enjoyed it and hope you guys enjoyed it
as well and regarding the steinit Saga I
have almost been ready to to to start it
and then then I got really sick and then
my daughter got sick and then I couldn't
continue preparing it for more than a
month and then uh well it just uh it
just uh got way out of hand but I it is
coming uh I just I just don't know to
which point but when it does uh you guys
will we will enjoy it as it will be
spectacular I I mean I I I enjoy it so
much just reading about Stein it's with
with the books that I'm preparing The
Saga with uh and there's just so much to
enjoy uh so yeah uh hopefully that comes
sooner than later but until then there
are other nice games that we can enjoy
while I'm still preparing it uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
and a little bit of extra info about uh
chess.com acquiring um at the play
magnets group uh I would like to thank
constantinos Lampard this Jeffrey
Clayman Miller Daniel Stone and David
grosskin for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions uh such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day